[Music]
what's up everyone we have the Tekken A8
collector edition in the office and boy
it has been quite a while since we've
had a Tekken game come out so I'm really
excited to see what's inside let's look
around the Box real quick we've got
kazer on the side and at the back of
course you know usual back stuff you got
great artwork you got little sneak PS
into the different features and
whatever's inside the game and on this
other side everything that's here will
be inside the box so we've got dlc's
we've got more dlc's and of course we
got the physical stuff we got a token
we've got a Leroy Smith metal ring pin
and badges we got eight collectible
cards the game of course the steelbook
and and of course the figurine which
lights up so I'm quite interested to see
how this looks like in person so let's
just open this up all right and I
believe we need to cut this open and get
my
knife slide
this very nice this the premium
collector box of course looks really
smooth of course we've got Jin on the
side and kazer on the other side so
that's how the Box looks like let's open
her
up all right first things first is the
pins that we get on here pretty sick
looking and of course they're all metal
let's just take it out real quick it's
are solid metal pins right
here proper metal pins we've got the
full game of course and I know many of
you like to see what's inside so let's
just do
that okay so here's how the game looks
like and opener up so that's about it of
course we going flip this around around
because the code is for us and at the
back there's no reversible cover it's
just Health precautions and warnings and
whatever so yeah of course what we want
to do is transfer the CD into the
steelbook which we'll be looking at in a
bit so let's put this aside all right
next up is the ultimate edition content
codes all right so we have the character
costume gold suit pack we have 32
costumes for that we've got Avatar skin
kingine and also the year one pass that
has four additional playable characters
so they'll be interested to see what
happens throughout the here of course
our Avatar skins for kazuya Jin and June
and there is a Avatar costume a classic
Tekken t-shirt and they have 32 designs
of that so that's pretty sick I'm
guessing this is meant for the arcade
mode next up is the steel book and of
course the characters are matte and the
background is glossy because you know
you don't want your background to
outshine your characters and when we
open it up we have this epic key art
between jyn and his father kazuya and
that's pretty sick on the inside however
it's just a bolt that I'm facing off and
there are two CDs this is a spot for two
CDs so that's oh that's interesting we
only have one
though wait one second let me just check
did I miss something out no it's just
the one oh that's interesting maybe
they've got DLC in the future you know
like the old days when we get to buy
another disc or expansion pack when we
used to call them expansion packs that'd
be quite sick you have two slots for
discs over here so that's interesting to
see in a steelbook but yeah that's it's
pretty sick stuff Let's uh move on to
the next bit all I kind of flip it
around and let's open her
up and oh okay I can see the figure
inside of course but first things first
is this let's remove the entire
thing damn that is cool there's a lot of
stuff going on here first things first
is the collectible cards oh and we've
got more tape to deal with I believe oh
what is it okay know everything just
kind of slides out all right so we have
eight collectible cards over
here Everything feels pretty glossy the
back 's pretty nice as well let's check
the front for the collectible cards
obviously the names the country of
origin fighting style rage art heat smch
and Alias so that's interesting we've
got Jin we've got kazuya June we've got
LS Nina favorite Ling claudo Asuka and
yeah that's that's all the cards we have
so so pretty interesting stuff that
we've got we got Italy we got China got
Ireland we got Sweden Japan and
apparently no one knows where Kazu is
from but I mean it's Japanese
so yeah can we assume that I'm not sure
let me know in the comments and Jin and
of course aukra so yeah these are all
the cards that you're going to get
pretty sick stuff of course if you're a
huge T fan if you want to keep these I
recommend like everyone else you know to
put these into Cod Steve so yep that's
it for the cods and let's move on to the
Statue so everything is on the inside of
this
package it's pretty tight in there so
nothing will fall out okay so before we
get to the Statue Let's uh see what this
is and what this is here is the
coin I we've got a coin here let's take
it out the back this is the arcade coin
that you get in game you got Kazu andin
facing off down here and of course the
back it just say arcade so it's always
nice when games add this into youres
it's always sick right it's how it
sounds like I mean it's really just
metal really good metal all right pretty
sick stuff it's it's it's got some he to
it as well right and of course oh yeah
this is the ring let's get it out the
back this is Leroy's ring all
right this ring is some heavy to it as
well it's a very pretty ring look at
that if you use that to bash someone in
that will leave a mark right kind of all
right on this thing all right look at
that that is pretty sick so it's a
pretty sick ring to have and it's inside
a nice pouch as well let's put that back
in and get to the main thing the piece
there is the
stones
Jin put him out there only one piece
that we need to insert which uh is this
Wing they have connectors down here
which we need to attach to the back and
of course we have a USBC usba cable on
the inside the spot is pretty prominent
so let's just line it up and put the
wing inside yep there we go all right
let's nice and snuck in there and look
at him in All His glory before we light
them up of course let's talk a little
bit about his statue I mean it looks
really good got nice detailing nice
shading as well up close it looks really
good that's really great texturing on
the left side here especially the
contrast between the red Black and
Whites on his right Li this looks really
good here things are glossy when it's
meant to be glossy things are matte when
it needs to be matte I don't see any
sort of manufacturing or painting
defects whatsoever you on the back you
got nice little details here of course
with his tattoo on his left arm and of
course our boy kicked up oh this so sick
so obviously when Jing goes devil mode
you know his little gem on here comes
out and that is that looks really good
with that out of the way let's uh plug
him in of course this appar lights up
I'm not sure about the helmet down here
but I know the base lights up as well oh
there we go
nice okay that's that is sick all right
let me just di Down the Lights real
quick that is proper sick look at that
okay shame the eyes on the helmet don't
light up but the eight lights up his
wings light up as well that is that is
proper garly this looks really good
looks like a really good pie piece
especially if you're going to put it in
a display cabinet or beside your PC this
looks really good with that um let's
wrap this up so that's it for the Tekken
8C and quite honestly there there's a
bit of value in this when it comes to
the Collectibles you get inside you've
got the ring you've got the arcade coin
you've got eight collectible cards
you've got the badges so nice little
things for you to wear about or you to
show off over there but of course the
biggest piece is our statue of Jin down
here that lights up here with his wing
and of course the eight here as well
well only thing to note is that this
eight isn't supposed to resemble the
eight on the Tekken 8 title this is
actually two chains linked up so that's
pretty cool on its own just in case you
guys are wondering why they look so
different that's the thing to note down
that they Two Chains so besides all the
physical stuff that's quite a bit of
digital content for you as well so all
in all this is a very comprehensive
package and if you're a Tekken fan you
you guys need to hop on this of course
the Gin statue is badass and you
definitely need to get your hands on
this if you're a true Die Hard Tekken
fan this will be such a sick edition to
the collection anyway if you have any
questions about the Tekken 8 collector
edition let me know in the comment
section down below and if you haven't
already make sure to follow us on all of
our socials right here to keep up to
date we post stuff every single day and
of course if you haven't make sure to
like And subscribe to us it goes a long
way in helping out the channel anyway
this is z have a great week ahead and
I'll catch youall
soon
[Music]